hey I'm Kevin hey I'm Austin hey I'm
Nick hey I'm Kyra hey I'm Brad Duggar
the creator of evil link and the editor
of webcomics calm and I'm Dave Kelly
cartoonist of Drive and Sheldon and
co-director of stripped together we're
the co-host of comic lab podcast and
today we're drawing Spongebob mashups
and we're sporting a 1974 Chicago
meatpacker mustache all right Austin so
to spin the wheel just go ahead and hit
spacebar there all right oh you know
gonna be cursed
oh yeah it's definitely gonna be cursed
I'm ready ok I can do that
oh you're so lucky all right let's get
to it
so now the thing is I haven't watched
spongebob in a hundred years I I've got
to kind of remember what he looked like
but I but I remember that I think if you
if you really want to talk process I
think half of it is keeping his overall
sponginess yeah like I think it'd
basically draw him the way your wife
would describe your midsection I think I
might think about like four spongebob at
least you know if this is a mash-up I
might think about like what are the
things that make spongebob spongebob but
then also like integrate some of the
shape language of Skeletor so what I'm
thinking is I'm trying to like I kind
want it to be a bit of an abomination
but like also sort of cute so I think
I'm gonna kind of like turn Pikachu into
like a sponge
how curse did we go ah I say we make it
like we take like as curse we can
possibly make it and then like we go
even a step beyond that I'm like a
sponge sponge Hulk or a Hulk Bob
Hulk Bob what about Hulk Bob yeah that
looks pretty good
okay Bob smash pants I love that Hulk
Bob smash pants that's amazing
now if you had to do your best current
personation Brad what would it Sally oh
boy uh hold on it's good you see okay
what I was saying is at any point go
ahead and start your let me hear your
Kermit you think you're so smart
ah hi-ho Kermit the Frog here three
little pigs oohs huh that's pretty good
I don't know what to do for the nose on
this just like Skeletor doesn't have a
nose but at the same time like spongebob
he knows is so iconic you should make it
like a whole like the nasal cavity but
then like that nose coming out of it oh
that's that's like that's like the stuff
of nightmares
you're like legit obsessed with Skeletor
I mean what is up with that I love him
he's such a good character first of all
he's so weird-looking he's like got this
Buffy man body but like a skull for a
head and like a really shrill voice he's
hilarious he's like the perfect example
of like its menacing but it's also like
incredibly silly he's like perfect
villain
so Austin you are a storyboard artist
and more flicks I am you are working on
cuphead right I am working on the
cuphead show that is very exciting
no it's really cool and you're right out
of school right yeah
I graduated last year Wow
and you're already a bored artist on the
show that's amazing
now what happens if you've already hit
perfection and you don't need the rest
of your minutes can I donate my minutes
to Dave Wow Wow Brad y'all think your
minutes secured how do you think you're
doing
I'm having a lot of fun I love the color
yellow so much so this is like very mez
so Brad if you had to describe it for
someone who had never heard of our
weekly podcast before a podcast comic
lab how would you describe it to someone
comic Lab is its studio talk you know
Eagle Kate it's it's if you were
listening to us talk in our studios as
we worked this is what you'd hear right
right two good friends who love comics
love hanging out and talking shop and
sharing all they know in terms of best
practices in terms of making a career
making a go of it yeah and working
independently on the web and laughing
the whole time yeah so what are you
thinking about color are you gonna make
him green or are you gonna make up
yellow um yeah ah we're gonna I'm saying
is like this that's what I'm talking
about you gotta just kind of like and
let life just like take you for a whirl
okay it's that's infuriating I can't
decide if I'm gonna give him spongebob
feet or Shrek feet and let me guess what
your answer is Austin yes you know what
I think you can read mine all right so
I'm wrapping up my spongebob bread and I
gotta tell you you can't see it yet but
the word gorgeous comes to mind it comes
to mind red well thank you very much but
how's your drawing it's going okay but
really frankly I'm just gonna be in fun
going through basically just stored
iPhoto photos of you and just I gotta
tell you bread this wedding rain comes
right off okay so for my finishing
touches I think
I'm just really it's just coloring most
of the thing I think I've added like the
majority of what I've wanted to
incorporate pikachu's you know markings
and stuff into this have a unit still
have to do the eyes but searching it's
looking cool I know I'm debating if I
should add the spongebob eyelashes oh I
am definitely doing a spongebob
eyelashes you know what I think I came
up with a pretty good mashup idea for
Kermit and span and SpongeBob ii-i've
came up with an idea that I think you're
gonna like a lot how's-how's Gollum
looking over there I'd say yeah it's I'm
happy with this with this mashup it's
pretty fun they're both they both have a
vaguely watery theme that I could play
off of which is good that's about all
you know what's fun in in drawing
spongebob is a brilliant design it's so
unique yeah you can tell this is a
character design that went through a lot
of iterations alright so I gave Shrek
Bob
spongebob color so the yellow right now
and now just for giggles I'm going to
Mick and green and see how that feels
and that is so much more cursed I'm
gonna keep it is green he has green now
I think if you combine spongebob and
Shrek the power of the means of the two
of them together would be unstoppable
done done perfect la chef skit so Nick
how do you think you did Oh
[Music]
it's often is something it's I mean I
think it's a good mashup between
Skeletor and SpongeBob uh which it's
it's something out into my nightmare
it's something out of my nightmare yeah
I'm so excited to see I did my best I
you know a father can only do so much he
is who he is at this point
all right let's what's up to each other
oh my god I was not ready it's such a
perfect mashup of Pikachu and SpongeBob
oh thank you yours is like probably what
Skeletor looks like as a child messed up
creepy child oh my goodness that is
fantastic
terrifying biting the head off of the
fish no there was something there's
something genuinely funny stylistically
about the fact that you chose from
squaring him off as this fun I think
that's delightful ection you made such
great choices like I love his small head
I love the fact that you kept his tie
his nipples are coming at you which
feels oddly appropriate but you see what
I was saying about making him making
mine green made him much more cursed
yeah and I like that it's like it gives
me like uncanny valley kind of vibes
it's like it's really like it's like the
worst thing I've seen in my life and I
hate it but also like he's precious I
love both of our cursed children equally
I think we've created new mega means
here you're welcome everyone hey thanks
for watching be sure to join us on
Instagram and Twitter for challenges
giveaways and the chance to have your
drawings featured on an upcoming show